the next thing i want to do is talk a
bit about the history of ai
and obviously the history of ai is going
to be necessarily abbreviated and
simplified here but i just want to give
you appreciation for how multifaceted
the history is and how
rich and somewhat sometimes
controversial it is
so a natural starting point to talk
about the history of ai is alan turing's
famous paper in 1950 called computing
machinery and intelligence
so in this paper he asked the question
can machines think
and he proposes the imitation game as
his solution
more popularly known as the turing test
and some of you probably know the turing
test is said to be passed by a machine
if it can fool a human judge into
thinking that it is actually a human
being
so this paper is remarkable not because
it built a system or proposed new
methods but it framed the philosophical
discussions of what is intelligence for
years to come
and you just have to appreciate how
difficult a notion
intelligence is to pin down so this was
really the first actionable
formal answer to the question can
machines think and now whether you
think that
working on a turing test is a good idea
that will lead to progress is
questionable and controversial but at
least philosophically it's quite
thought-provoking
so for us one major takeaway of the
turing tests which was not really
highlighted
is this objective specification
so note that the test itself
is
meant to be capturing what a system
ought to be doing
independent of how you get there it
doesn't say whether it should be using
neural networks or logic based methods
or so on
and this modularity is going to be
really important to us in the
in this course
so at the end of the paper train does
speculate on what might work so he talks
about two possible approaches you could
take a top-down approach and try to
tackle abstract problems such as chess
this is the route taken by symbolic ai
you could also
quote unquote um
provide a machine with the best sense
organs and aka sensors and teach it like
a child
and this is more of the approach taken
by neural and statistical ai
and both have been tried
and we'll see
how all three
uh
types of ai symbolic neural statistical
kind of meld together at the end
so to start our first story let's go to
the summer of 1956. the place was
starmeth college
john mccarthy who actually founded the
stanford ai lab and
organized a workshop he gathered the
brightest minds of the time
in attendance with marvin minsky alan
newell herbert simon all of whom want to
make seminal contributions ai
and the participants set out a
not so modest proposal it was to
they claim that every aspect of learning
or any other feature intelligence can be
so precisely described that a machine
can be made to simulate it
so they were really after the moon
they were after generality
and this was post-war computers were
just coming on the scene it was a really
exciting time and people were really
ambitious
so during this time there were a few
systems that were built um arthur samuel
built a computer program that could play
chat checkers at a reasonable amateur
level and actually featured some uh you
know machine learning
um
ali newell and herbert simon
came up with a logic theorist that could
prove theorems
for one theorem they actually found a
proof that was better than the human
written proof and they tried to submit a
paper on the result but the paper got
rejected because
the reviewers said it was not a new
theorem
what the reviewers didn't realize that
the third author was actually a computer
program
later they worked generalized these
ideas to the general problem solver
which
was aimed at solving any problem
provided it could be suitably encoded in
logic and again this carries forward the
ambitious general intelligence
agenda
sand this was a time of high optimism
with the leaders of the field who are
all really impressive thinkers
predicting ai would be solved in a
matter of years
but we know that
they didn't get solved in 10 years and
there were some
tasks such as machine translations which
were very stubborn
so this is now a folklore story i don't
know how true it is but it's amusing
nonetheless um you take a sentence like
the spirit is willing but the flesh is
weak
translate it into russian which was the
favorite language for translation in the
50s and you translate it back
and then you get the vodka is good but
the meat is rotten
so
uh this was
less than amusing to the government
funding agencies
who decided to write a report showing
how really machine translation wasn't
going anywhere and cut off funding this
led to the first ai winter
so what went wrong here
so there's two things
first is that most of the approaches
involved casting problems as logical
reasoning which required a search over
an exponentially large state space and
the hardware at the time was just simply
too limited
and secondly
even if the research had infinite
compute they would still not be able to
solve ai because there's just too many
concepts in the world words objects and
all this information has to somehow be
put
into the ai system
so these grand ambitions weren't
realized but nonetheless there were some
useful contributions
many due to john mccarthy that came out
of this era
first lisp was invented for ai and
arguably it's still the world's most
advanced programming language
garbage collection is something that if
you're programming only in python it
allows you to not know what garbage
collection is and time sharing the
ability to use a single computer by
multiple people was prescient at the
time
so then fast forward to the 70s and 80s
knowledge was the key word
and ai researchers thought knowledge was
the key to combat both the computation
and information limitations of the
previous era
and at that time expert systems became
very fashionable
where a domain expert could encode
knowledge in the form of rules usually
looking like this
and
there was a noticeable shift
as well to solve it all optimism from
the 50s and 60s was gone and instead
researchers focused on very practical
systems targeted at particular domains
for example chemistry medical diagnosis
and
business operations
and
there were some good things knowledge
did help
curb both the information complexity and
also restricted the space state space so
that it alleviated the computation
burden
and this was the first time that ai had
real
applications on industry
but there were obviously problems
deterministic rules couldn't handle the
complexity and uncertainty in the real
world and moreover these rules just
became quickly too complex to create and
maintain
so this is a quote from terry buenergrad
who some of you know was on the hci
faculty at stanford but before he was a
hdf faculty he worked at mit as an ai
researcher
and
this is what he had to say in the mid
70s you thought that it was a dead end
there was just too many complex
interactions between all the components
no easy footholds and you just couldn't
hold the comp
have a mental model what was going on in
your head
and moreover there was a lot of
over-promising and under-delivering
field collapsed again
and it really seemed that history was
repeating itself
so at this point we're going to leave
aside the story of symbolic ai which
dominated ai for multiple decades
and go back in time to 1943 to tell the
story of neural ai
so 1943 is the year often attributed to
the birth of artificial neural networks
so mccollum pitts
devised a simple model that
and study mathematical properties of the
simple model
but they didn't do anything in a way of
learning
the model's parameters in 1946 there was
a first learning rule by donald hebb
based on the mantra that cells that fire
together wired together it was nice and
simple but it didn't really work 1958
rose and black came up with a perceptron
algorithm for learning single-layer
artificial neural networks aka linear
classifiers which actually turned out to
work really well
even was used even fairly recently
59 there was analog for linear
regression by woodrow and hoff
they came up with actually a multi-layer
generalization called madeline
which was actually used to eliminate
echoes on phone lines at the time and
this was one of the first real world
applications of neural networks
and then 1969 this was a big year
so marvin minsky seymour pappard wrote a
small book called perceptrons
and they analyzed perceptrons with
varying mathematical properties
and they had a little almost trivial
result that showed that single-layer
perceptron couldn't recognize the xor
function
and even though that is said nothing
about the capabilities deep networks
somehow this book is largely credited
with
shutting down neural networks research
and the continued rise of symbolic ai
it's a really kind of interesting piece
of history and i you know encourage you
to go examine it
in the 80s our neural networks started
coming back again
1980 was the first convolutional neural
network um which was trained in a kind
of a ad hoc way 1986
romahart hinton-williams
reinvented
and popularized back propagation from
multi-layer networks and now training
became a little bit more principled 1989
yamachan
devised a convolutional network that was
able to recognize handwritten digits
and was actually deployed for the use at
usps to recognize zip codes
and this was one of the first major
success stories of using neural networks
um but
until the mid 2000s neural network's
research was still fairly niche i would
say and they were very notorious hard to
train
in 2006 this kind of started changing
jeff hinton and his colleagues had a
paper showing how you could use
unsupervised layer-wise pre-training to
mitigate some of these
facts and the term deep learning started
getting used around this time as well
but it was really
2012. i would say that was a real kind
of the major break for neural networks
so alice
chuzzkevsky elias suscover and jeff
hinton wrote this landmark paper
um which came up with what is now called
alexnet a convolutional network which
had huge huge gains in object
recognition
and at the time computer vision
community was very skeptical and almost
overnight it completely transformed the
field think about computer vision
without neural networks today that's
kind of um this almost feels like kind
of distant memory almost
2016 was another big event alphago
defeated they said oh and go something
that experts thought was still many
decades away and that just kind of
firmly more established deep learning as
a dominant
paradigm in ai
and this kind of continues even to the
modern day
um but
let's reflect so far so we have seen two
intellectual traditions symbolic ai
which is roots
in logic and neural ai with its roots in
neuroscience
the two have fought fiercely over the
decades over philosophical differences
but i want to suggest some food for
thought maybe there are deeper
connections here
so remember that nicole and pitt's paper
that introduced neural networks and
arguably the root of deep learning well
they spent most of the time talking
about how it can actually encode logical
operations
and the game of go which is actually a
perfectly logical game
designed by a few elegant simple rules
but alphago use the power pattern
matching capabilities of neural networks
to solve this otherwise logical game
so there may be room for more symbiosis
than we think
so now there's a third and final story
that we must tell to complete the
picture
so this story is not really about ai per
se but it's about the influx of certain
other ideas from other areas that have
helped shape and form a mathematical
foundation
for ai and we call this statistical ai
so machine learning is very
popular but the idea of fitting models
from data goes which is at the core of
machine learning goes far back
even to uh gauss and legend and at the
beginning of the
19th century we developed at least
squares for linear regression
classification was also very early in
statistics
and ai also consists of sequential
decision-making problems for
deterministic versions dijkstra's
algorithm from the algorithms community
for uh models with uncertainty from
control theory bellman created markov
decision processes
um and notice that all these
developments largely predated um the 50s
which
and 40s where ai really kind of started
springing up
so you might have noticed if you're
paying close attention that
where we left symbolic ai was at the end
of the 80s
but where neural ai started really
gaining traction was
the 2010s so what was going on between
and what was going on between was that
there was a period where the term ai
wasn't
really used at least not to the extent
that it is today
and i think that part of it was to
distance um
to add distance to the failed attempts
of the recent account of ai winter
and also because the goals were just
more down to earth people talked about
machine learning
and then during that period there were
two paradigms
there was bayesian networks developed in
80s by judea pearl which provided
reasoning under uncertainty framework
which is something that a symbolic ai
didn't have a satisfying answer for 1995
support vector machines were developed
derived from ideas from learning theory
and optimization
and at that time svms were easier to
turn tuned than neural networks and
really became the favorite tool in
machine learning before deep learning
started taking off again
so to kind of wrap up
you know the there's three stories that
we talked about symbolic ai
took a top-down approach
and really failed to deserve on its
original promise but it did offer a
vision and built impressive artifacts
like question answering and dialogue
system managing trying to do this on
ancient hardware in the 60s
neural ai took a completely different
approach proceeding bottom up starting
with simple perceptual tasks which the
symbolic community wasn't interested at
a time i compared machine translation
with removing echoes on phone lines for
example but in the end it offered a
class of models and a way of thinking
about data that has proven
capable of conquering
today's ambitious problems
and finally statistical ai
foremost
for us will offer mathematical rigor and
clarity for example in the course when
we define define objective functions
separate from optimization or have a
language to talk about the complexity of
a model in learning
these ideas and language all stem from
statistical ai and the course will
actually be presented mostly through the
lens of statistical ai but i want to
highlight that all three views are kind
of compatible and just offer different
advantages on the same underlying
ideas
stepping back you know the modern world
of ai is kind of like new york city it's
a melting pot that has drawn largely
from a lot of different fields
statistics algorithms neuroscience
economics and it's really a symbiosis
between all these fields and how they
come together and allow you to tackle
real-world applications that makes our
ai so rewarding
okay so that ends the
uh the ai
history module
you can read much more about it at a few
links at the end of these slides